-You know, Germany has
with it’s history, with it’s responsibility
toward these wars
has something to add to that conversation.
We cannot tell a hero’s journey.
We cannot have a mission
that you have to do
and then, in the end you’re successful.
A German soldier cannot come
successful out of the movie.
-I’m so sorry.
-That the balance
especially when you’re writing
of knowing or hoping
that you’re going to get
incredible actors to be in each of these parts.
There is a part of your brain that is thinking
I want to justify each one of these people.
-Because tonight,
in this very room,
a murder
will be committed.
My murder.
-The important thing about this film
is although it is about somebody
who gets a
a very gloomy diagnosis
it’s actually a film about
not about dying
it is about living.
-The results have come back.
I’m afraid this time
they’re pretty conclusive.
It’s never easy, this.
-Quite.
-During the writing of the film
also during the shooting and in the editing of the film
we were, we found ourselves,
time and again, leaning towards recreating
moments of the film and we found, time and again, that
the more we let go of the original movie
and went in our own direction the film became
much more true.
-The end is inevitable, Maverick.
Your kind is headed for extinction.
-Maybe so, sir.
But not today.
-When I see the film
I’m able to kind of see all of our
all of these little tendrils of different people’s
thoughts and dreams in the film
and so, your sort of able to be proud of it
in a different way than if it was just your voice
and that’s been thrilling.
-We know that we are bruised
and infected
and pregnant
and terrified
and insane
and
some of us are dead!
-More than anything
I just wanted to
be part of
a really good story.